une quinzaine de vendangeurs et depuis
ce matin les ouvrages dans les vignes de
riz parmi eux trois personnes placées
sous la main de la justice soit
incarcéré une première au berry qui
donne satisfaction j'ai commencé ce
matin ça apprend un peu comme on le
raisin comment il est cultivé
comment il est mise en bouteille tout ce
à quoi un projet porté par le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation le spip qui suit des détenus
et a sélectionné les trois vendangeurs
encadré sur le terrain par un
surveillant volontaire c'est la
continuité du travail en
on n'est pas juste en tant que
surveillant là pour
les accompagner juste en prison si on
peut les accompagner à l'extérieur ce
jour de d'initiatives pour une
initiative que connaît bien le préfet de
l'indre ancien directeur national de la
pénitentiaire à la base il ya un souhait
de l'administration pénitentiaire de
construire d'autres parcours de
réinsertion professionnelle qui
correspondent aux besoins du terroir
dans notre département on a des
viticulteurs il se trouve qu'on a des
viticulteurs qui sont en recherche de
main-d'oeuvre non pas en recherche de
main d'oeuvre sous payée ou moins payé
puisqu'ils sont rémunérés comme comme
des saisonniers mais qui ont
objectivement des difficultés de
recrutement qui ça qui s'aggrave d'année
en année permettre l'insertion et
surtout et d une filière qui manque de
personnel c'est un secteur en tension
par rapport au recrutement
pas seulement au moment des vendanges
les besoins de main d'oeuvre sont tout
au long de l'année je pense qu'il faut
voir surtout plus loin c'est pas c'est
pas une semaine de vendanges qui va
quitter tout va changer les choses c'est
plutôt d'un travail qui peut se faire
sur plusieurs activités sur toute une
année viticole et qui peuvent au final
intéresser quelques quelques personnes
redécouvrir un collectif de travail une
vraie rémunération mettre en place des
règles et surtout susciter des vocations
tout ça sans modération